oh [ __ ] Anderson's coming son in the  fight's so close oh  get off the ropes Jakey get off the  ropes Anderson no Anderson's like I  gotta finish this [ __ ] kid oh [ __ ]  oh  my God Anderson's Rock dude late round  he's gonna drop he's rocked Daddy was  right  now that's a fight yeah let's take a  fight holy [ __ ]  that's my thing like Anderson I told you  in the outclass some technical and  volume but Jake has the power and now  this gives Jake energy well not and  Harrison's Taking Chances oh  this is nuts dude if he finishes them  here  Wow Come on Jake well Anderson's gonna  have to take chances if he takes chances  he's gonna get knocked out yeah he's  gonna get knocked out but Anson's being  pretty concentrated he's probably still  a little cobwebs up there okay maybe not  get out of there  God damn it I mean he's won the round